from the start why does one run
ruin - it old
fascination
[Music]
[Applause]
appreciation has been most intelligent
on the success of your performance what
I'm saying is that I have lived in the
grip of Feist pleasure
Oscar Wilde the Centers of the cult is
that you'll be imprisoned and kept to
hard labor for two years it was wrong
and I have paid will make a classic of
you yet only unlike dear Jesus you have
luggage
they intend to effect a reconciliation
with my wife I feel sure that if I was
to see him once I would forgive him a
prison rest assured I shall never see
Lord Alfred Douglas again I forbid him
did it without infernal man
okay let's run away someone no one could
find us you don't know I you say then
you will never see Constance again but
wearing a silk stockings today I go too
far sir thank you go too far
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you figured everything my family my work
my freedom everything nothing
suffering is nothing when there is love
love is everything
I was the love and be labored but the
price I pay for it
[Music]
and kinda do to speak to me you couldn't
let me five dance could you
I'm in mortal combat with this wallpaper
Robbie mine ever since ago
you